[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alemanno
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sacha une base
18 années de barre minimale
champion des marmites vain pendant 18
années passées lundi qu'est ce que tu
peux nous expliquer ce que tu fais alors
le but c'est de montrer tout ce que les
gens ne voient pas la télé n'a comme on
avait pu pendant les magnétos c'est
parce que vous êtes un petit peu fou fou
à l'antenne vous êtes fou fou
auront-elles aussi il est chroniqueur
aussi donc on essaye de montrer tout ça
très voilé génial ça va alors est ce que
tu veux commencer ta chronique
maintenant où est ce que tu veux en
venir ultérieurement
vu ça mais vu les noms s'associer vaut
mieux les faire maintenant d'accord et
sa fille et de nouvelles chaussures
alors c'est notre cd v basket
maintenance et et qui nous soucier de
basket se découpent si les couples un
des coups l'un des couples at on bien ça
va bâtir une économie charrier donc
j'avais plus petits pays d'habitude
méchant alors vous savez les pieds comme
ça
la coupe était ongles allez
on y va série pouvait pas tant la
semaine prochaine puisque en cette
approche de fin de saison des têtes vont
tomber cyril des hommes mariés risque
d'être célibataire à la fin de cette
chronique booba castaldi le fixer
c'est le retour de la gazette of tout ce
que vous n'auriez pas la télé mais leur
mémoire ça tombe bien je suis payé pour
ça voilà m baye
[Rires]
pension alimentaire
et on commence avec un chroniqueur qui
ne sera plus la saison prochaine
puisqu'il a osé s'en prendre à la maman
de ma mère veut vraiment tenir à
les chiens guides pour aller couper
peut-être sur l'espionnage
chinois
la danse mathieu après la flamme et le
flambeau découvrez la flemme avec babar
devront leur frère faire on ne fait rien
frère on ne fait rien mais question
vient 18h40 vous fait des missions très
chaud et chocolat je suis au paddle moi
toute la journée vous annoncions toute
la journée
petit message pour les invités quand
vous venez sur pacte au tpp un conseil
soyez toujours bien coiffée par cécile
en même temps
beaucoup évolué il ya beaucoup beaucoup
et fort
les fans du que mes épaules a retrouvé
un perturbateur du plateau cyril non ce
ne sont pas les anglais c'est bernard
montiel si merci d'être là alors ton
histoire allait à l'incroyable et je
voudrais dire merci à tous qu'est ce qui
se passe c'est eficien et je suivais ses
sièges
benjamin castaldi était interpellé par
quelque chose cette heure regarder les
gens des soins que tout ce que touche se
transforme en or mais par quoi manger et
il peut être perturbé aura sur le
plateau le retour de rachid arhab ou une
maquilleuse très joli
d'ailleurs les gens disent oh comme tout
ce que je touche se transforme en or
et pour finir c'est omettre sur ces 8 on
assistait à la finale de la ligue des
champions de la sucette
mais là je m'entraîne de ouf
j'ai joué même le numéro un modèle je te
jure que c'est vrai les manifs rejoint
ma niche qui a impressionné on m'a dit
franchement tu joue très bien non mais
il m'a dit et m'a dit combien je te vois
tu peux tu es bien foutu moi je mens tu
as besoin sur
ce qu'il veut faire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
s'agrandir unanime et j'adore j'adore
ces mêmes dans les
pas des mots que tu connais pas
[Rires]
franchement
comme elle c'est vrai le master chief et
rendez vous en terre inconnue
alors c'est juste vous l'entendez
et encore on n'a pas vu ce qu'il a dit
c'est pareil il a dit cela dit je suis
fou amoureux de ma femme est en fait ils
regardaient pas du tout d'ailleurs car
des nourrisons
sichem aurore
compter sur les amis série merci
beaucoup à quoi tu achètes de sauver
conab mauvais sort et marie coûteaux de
ma gueule c'est très très grave
chantal et aurait fait ça ah ouais moi
je tiens
merci aura quand même la décision la
vraie leçon de thaler qui ont expliqué
qu'ils ne sont que c'est très bon signe
au contraire à bercy veut dire qu'il est
impossible est la vote à raison c'est
vrai après tout il peut être très bien
amoureux d'horreur et regarder ce qui se
passe c'est ce qu'il voit rien
sa démission
je sais même pas ce qui la regarde et
j'aurais dit que c'était le père vais
tous les hommes regardent c'est vraiment
pas moi aussi d'ailleurs belle feinte de
passe
regardez c'est exactement badamassi que
je vous regarde
comme ça
[Applaudissements]
en effet bon choix
je confirme j'ai ma chronique la semaine
prochaine
cette table il ya un chroniqueur qui a
complètement pété un câble tiens encore
là en début d'émission ce à ses juges il
ya ma mère qui vous répond il va se
faire [ __ ] de leurs maux
c'est lui qui est dur à gérer et même
très dur je vais m'en occuper
mais oui les gars je pense qu'elle peut
te mettre un mollard
battant monaco
prend un peu encadrera la dacquoise qui
ont dit la vérité et je le dirai plus
jamais et je n'ai pas qu'ici elle a
rencontré quelqu'un avec qui je tourne
embrouille vraiment élu à amiens mollard
mais c'est pas de ma mère dans la rue tu
un scénario mermoud là
bas les colts n'ont
rien du tout mais c'était amical
séminaire de fin d'année la salle
offrait un vrai rien ne vaut une bonne
recrue plaît bien j'adore aller oui je
disais c'est elle qui a autour de ces
quelqu'un qui a complètement lâché la
rampe c'est guillaume genton me sens
concerné oui il a complètement lâché la
rampe je ne sais pas si vous avez
toujours pour ambition passer les
vacances avec lui
moi je serai pas très chaud regardez
c'est à gafsa au p'tit cul
[Musique]
maintenant on m'avait cette damnée viens
moi guillaume je pourrais vider mon pel
pour vous tenir la main
ça m'avait déjà un fantasme inavoué
c'est de vous dessinez nu au fusain
[Applaudissements]
- comme un kebab
une caresse les cheveux
dans le cou ste claire
bref moi l'été parce qu'en l'écoutant
bien mais
là soient touchés des petites boulettes
[Applaudissements]
bien
qu'avec je ne vois pas ça se savait pas
plus c'est quand même fou cette émission
il ya un truc un rien vendre je sais pas
il ya un ace que vous laissez
pas ce qui m'a pris je crois que vous
mérite pas
vraiment que tu mérites c'est bon
vous emmerdez pacs bonsoir oui c'est
plus un secret pour personne vous n'etes
pas la personne la plus présente au sein
de la société h2o productions la moto
est pleine de l'attentât vous avez un
peu de recul disons c'est vrai que j'ai
plus un animateur c'est plus un
producteur vous êtes un champion en
devenir après le tennis après avoir
acquis un niveau très sympathique au
paddle le loustic a une nouvelle lubie
la boxe alors vous à la maison vous avez
peut-être suivi ça ces derniers jours et
vous avez envie de voir les images de
cyril à la boxe est bien c'est que lundi
que je suis payé pour ça j'ai réussit à
choper des images de l'entrée du bourg
nous avons un oui ça tombe bien je
l'aiderai coup tu as tu es con
[Musique]
les entraînements c'est le choc
youssef que j'embrasse bien sûr
mais là
oui
j'ai dit j'ai vraiment de la bonne chère
actuellement à 10 minutes c'est très dur
c'est très dur c'est très très dur chez
les anglais tout d'abord alors c'est
comment on n'en fait rien ce sont bien
sûr sens très bien se voir son joli nous
est dit qu
pour pas complexés benjamins qui se
colle maintenant parce que matin il y
avait forcément y'a pas de vanne
forcément mais quand vous avez vu le
téléphone vous êtes pas dit ouais là bas
ils pas des trucs un peu bizarres parce
que cyril même à la boxe ça reste cyril
collot regarder
[Musique]
r je
tiens mes meilleurs amis en
commun
c'est vrai
c'est mon pote à michael j'embrasse
d'ailleurs celle bellity dans les
meilleurs amis il adore s'habiller aussi
bluffé il adore ça
c'est la danse à la nation je le fais
tout le temps il me le fais tout le
temps voilà ajoute je n'arrête pas oui
avant mais j'ai une bonne nouvelle non
mais est ce que vous savez que vous êtes
nommé aux prochains nrj music awards je
ne savais pas mais oui oui dans la
catégorie la catégorie révélation
franco-tunisienne l'année voici tout un
artiste complet davy repousse sans cesse
les limites du champ lexical
elle a cartonné avec leur reprise du
titre damir on dirait est là et le et ce
magnifique leurs tests l'orchestré
philharmonique voici tout de suite
attiré là
après le succès international de la
chanson i'm here on dirait
ça non
découvrez la version locale de bab al
aziz on dirait que tu pue du cul on
dirait que tu pue du cul
on dirait bien que c'est toi on dirait
quand on prétend que ça pue du cul on
dirait on dirait bien que ces castes à
la la la la la la la
la la la la la
c'est qu'à sa wii qui pue du cul c'est
qu'à ça
dirait on dirait bien que c'est toi on
dirait que ça pue tutu on dirait on
dirait bien que ces castes halal
de toi lorsque tu pue du cul mais on
croit bien que ces soirs
où tout le monde autour de toi parce que
tu pue du cul probité plus du cas ça on
dirait
on dirait bien que c'est toi odile elle
casse appliquées on dirait on dirait
bien créé ces cas là
[Applaudissements]
ah la la la la la la la
d'emblée comme ça voilà prêt tristesse
de cette séquence c'est que tout le
monde sauf les
nouvelles
non mais vraiment c'est venu seul et
donc j'essaie d'être impeccable
[Rires]
mais c'est mon coeur pour le coffre
[Applaudissements]